[Music]  the Lightning's have resolved to  exterminate us  they have a new leader at Marius he  wants the blood of Celine  if they use it the Lycans power will be  limitless  there's never been a large-scale like in  the time  there is never been a Marius protector  do I look worried  you must go north  you will find answers that  war has followed you here Marius if you  meant to win this war  you will need to go further than even a  warrior of your renown has ever ventured  before  impossible  [Music]  looking for someone  there's nothing stopping her now  what I want is your blood can't guess it  she is the purest of us all I'm not that  pure  [Music]  there are too many of them do I look  worried